yeah hello welcome to this video
yeah this is a somewhat different video
and it's due to the fact that today
fifty years ago um Gary Kasparov was
born so he celebrates his 50th birthday
today I was just coming across when the
line in the chest a new site that this
is the case that I wasn't really aware
of that I was aware that he should turn
50 this year but not that this is the
day and I thought it would be a good
chance to maybe show one or two games of
course Kasparov games are well known so
I tried to pick something that is
probably known to some of you but not
all of you
you could easily Pickens probably
greatest game ever the one against
Apollo from 1999 why he made it that
Apollo's King on on the first rank being
white a funny game and yeah but about
everybody knows that game so I tried to
look for something that is so nice but
not super well known probably and this
is these are actually Buddha games are
picked to two games so on the first one
here Kasparov playing black against
Makarov mcgraw officer grandmaster now
he's a couple of years older than
Kasparov and they're both from Baku
today this is in Azerbaijan of course
but back then it was the Soviet Union
because power of odds I was born in Baku
if I'm not mistaken and this is a
training game that has been played that
was played in 1977 so you need to put
this in context 1977 really sounds like
a long time ago back then known as far
off was you can calculate now 14 years
old which nowadays would
with his kind of stature that you would
look at young grandmaster traveling from
tournament to tournament but this is not
the case we are talking about the Soviet
Union yet
Kasparov at that time probably never had
left the country
maybe he played a youth event or
something but he I don't I don't think
he I even got an ego rating it was a
different time back then they didn't
travel abroad so much so this was a
training game and it was clear that
Kasparov was very talented junior and
they wanted to have some training
experience I guess against a slightly a
widow but also in comparison young
player in the case of Makarov I think he
was nineteen nineteen or twenty is like
five years older so let's see what
happened in this game so another
classical opening here with the Queens
gambit declined maybe slight surprise if
you know that kaswell of course is a
champion of that dynamic openings later
like the Gould hurt or the Kings Indian
defense but he also played lots of lots
of games in the classical Queens gambit
here was black and it was his main
defense and the first matches against
Karpov I guess also under the influence
of the trainer's that he had they always
put heavy emphasis on learning classical
structures and and studying games by but
we need kappa blanka
and so on so we have from the Queens
gambit here and in fact it's the tartar
Koba variation or as I think it is in
the the Russian Circles they usually
call it tarik over maka gone
upon the rescue variation the TMB tmb in
german on yeah well this is probably the
most popular line within the classical
Queens gambit even nowadays it was the
most popular line back then and the
1760s championed by Geller and Spassky
and Kasparov and Karpov both played this
line extensively the world championship
matches is this so the perfectly good
option for black and that addresses the
main point the main issue of the Queens
gambit declined this is of course the
bishop on c8 which yeah needs to find a
role in the game and as white doesn't
exchange the moment like tries to
fianchetto the bishop to to activate it
yeah White has range a wide range of
possibilities now the classical choice
that for example Fischer played in the
72 match was to take nowadays this is
considered a bit bit harmless and the
most popular move nowadays is probably
Bishop e2 but White has hasn't proven
anything in this in this opening it
still has solar disabled for black or
Bishop d3 sorts of option in nowadays
yeah maguro of plate Queen b3 which is
an interesting move that's a very safe
move but still interesting yeah it
applies direct pressure on d5 so black
needs to react in some way played Bishop
d7 which is normal I'm protecting d5 and
now white exchanged on f6 and took on d5
yeah what's the point why is white
giving up the bishop here
the issue is some white wants to provoke
like to recapture here with the pond so
that Bishop is biting biting on granite
black also doesn't want to give up the
bishop so this is not a great move also
you have some some direct problems here
with the light squares don't want to do
that so you get this position with eat
xt5 and this now is an issue like this
bishop is not doing much and what white
is saying in addition tried to do like
this wolf root d1 to put lots of
pressure on divider so that black has
problems with playing c5 activating the
pieces and fighting to get the typical
hanging pawns c5 has also moved that
make sure that this Bishop is doing
something so what is Plex supposed to do
the thing is if you look at c5 which is
the move you want to play white captures
and then this immediately here problem
of course you also cannot recapture
simply the special saying so it's it's
it's quite quite tricky so what what did
Kasparov claim a passive move c6 or some
other Ruth no let's see five so what's
what's the point the point is that after
taking of course as mentioned black
cannot retake but black can simply play
the smooth ninety seven developing a
piece and intending to take on c5 and
this is a very typical solution typical
of this opening and also very typical of
Kasparov style he always wanted to get
active play and let the pieces work
and he wasn't yeah huge fan of
maneuvering you pieces around and
playing for for small things I mean he
could do that he was excellent in all
parts of the game but he preferred to
play a dynamic chess if possible
so what happens if white takes all v6
and what happens if his F is greedy
that's more than one idea but one
possibility is night to c5 activating
then let's just say queen retreats and
black takes and this is a very active
position I've got great piece activity
so black has some has excellent play for
the pawn this
also after taking also this move isn't
as bad because it activates this look at
something
so taking isn't so great
what is why it's supposed to do yeah it
can take on you can actually take on on
d5 yeah have a look at that but light
takes and now it gets a bit tricky this
Knight is hanging if you take f6 lose
check this is also not helping now the
queen is hanging at this Knight is under
tech and if the Queen moves you have yet
another lose here which may be at some
point threatened something yeah look at
the development great bishops here the
active a good good night the King is
still in the center and white needs to
miss the bishop and castle to get a
complete development black has excellent
play here so I'm very
dynamic way to handle this and this also
shows that the Queens gambit declined
isn't necessarily always some dull
opening or a dull position
what did McGraw mauve play played c6
this is quite quite good too attacking
and just gives away the pawn to make
sure that that that it is not so so
dynamic and quickly coming blacks play
um yeah what now he could actually take
you it's not it's not a terrible move he
didn't do that but I just want to show
it I'm a possible continuation is 95
Jack takes and Queen c3 after which
black he just takes and now he has
excellent chances to get the pawn back
and equalize the game um there are many
you see I think rook c8 is one more
maybe just 94 you will get this point
back in the long run and have about
equal play this is probably what white
should have done he played Knight d4
however she looks perfectly normal
but it actually has a drawback and
because borrow from does an excellent
job here to show what is the drawback
what he's doing now is a very very
concrete and strong play he just took it
this is not so easy actually to think of
this move and it looked simple but why
would you give up your excellent f6
Bishop for this night okay it's a good
night on default this day it's not a bad
piece but still your bishop looks
excellent
yeah McGraw moth took with the rock and
in fact them taking with the porn was
maybe the wiser decision
it doesn't look radium but it at least
takes these two squares and yeah that
prevents what what happened in the cave
you will see that gets tricky
yeah Black has a good position he can
play Queen g5 rupee eight it's it's
simply an active good position and white
needs to spend some time to to even get
castled he hasn't a lot yet this is an
important feature of the Queens gambit
declined black is castling very quickly
here on new five while white often hangs
around a bit and does things on the
Queen side and a little bit of here and
there and he doesn't castle so this is
often a source of counter play ok took
it 95 with tempo so it's it's very
forced the Queen returned also to
increase the pressure attacking and it
needs to go to the to there's no other
move yeah now that the key move which is
the point of all this of course default
it's very very typical the isolated pawn
the the whole power of the pieces gets
get unleashed a few managed to advance
the pawn and now black again gets an
excellent position here in fact probably
McGraw Marshall played 92 it's not it's
not a very attractive looking move I am
I admit it but it's not so clear black
actually has a huge advantage after
there are many ways to get a good
position one is to go here and just to
just sacrifice this something like this
this is excellent for black somebody
because white has big problems to even
get the pieces into play this this rook
and the bishop are not playing and if
you move the bishop you must be careful
of with g2 like and black can often just
take it and play against the bad king at
the end but he should have done that
it's it's better than the game he took
it and this now leads to leads to an
attack yeah you can easily see that the
e-file now is the the Avenue for for the
attack
what about this moves it looks very very
dangerous allowing a discovered check
but it's probably the move that Makarov
should have played it's um it's good for
black but it's still a position you can
fight let's say here it's not it's not
attractive I know but so I can't even
return here because you cannot take it
very embarrassing quite funny so black
cannot take it and this means you need
to go let's say here then like just
retreats and enjoys a good position but
it's still a game it's not a forced win
what mcgraw more plate is f3 he tends to
secure the King here on foot if you want
to draw it that way but in this position
Kasparov found a very nice solution if
you don't know the game is maybe Nadia
to pause and look a bit at this position
what could be an interesting way to
continue the attack iam ok show you know
because part of took on f3 Bishop
sacrifice and it is very very strong
let's start with the would easy the IDI
lines if it takes with the Queen
then there's justice check here and
black wins the Queen or maybe like this
it's it's just the Queen for rook and
Bishop should be a rather easy win so
it's the pollen capture
that you need to calculate this this was
played of course and now the check yeah
now it you can maybe continue a couple
of moves here this is not difficult to
calculate this is of course not only
direct made so we have to must be played
and then 94 track check what now the
King cannot move and if you move the
knight cute mate so Bishop b2 this was
all easy to for c-93 check it's all
Pinter so you need to go here with the
King track check
only one move rook g2 as necessary an
all-night h4 and I'm not sure I mean I
can only speculate how how deep he
calculated this I think probably a lot
longer maybe till the end of the game
it's possible but this is the position
if you if you if you are normal human
being and you're not Kasparov you can
maybe this is very linear there are not
many alternatives and in this position
you can you can judge beforehand that
okay if everything else fails you win
the exchange back and then from material
point of view you okay and you still
have an attack so this is the worst that
can happen
but in fact it is it is much worse it's
not just winning the exchange back yeah
what does it have a movie needs to I
mean yes this movie that this is the
only one needs to cover the rook and
yeah what now how does black can improve
the position and this is a very
important role every what Roman rule
that's a very important rule that very
often to really finish off an attack and
win the game you need to get all pieces
involved and this basically cries for
this move now both rooks
work in the in the center yeah of course
just attacking the Queen and the Queen
needs to move yeah he went to e1 he
could also try to go to a forum but then
black has the strong move Knight f5 with
various ideas one being 93
this is just just a simple line so it's
very forced you cannot go here for
example you to go to f3 to block it
thank you
win the Queen yeah it's just just one
line it's is simply an absolutely deadly
attack so he went to he went to e1 which
is probably also the more logical with
keeping the Queen close to to defend and
in this position there's more than one
way to win nowadays you can easily check
this with an engine but Kasparov in a
normal game between two human beings he
found a very swift solution played roopd
3 and the idea being to play rook f3
winning the Queen yeah because the
bishop needs to check that so if white
would play that same zero move man this
one is just winning and you pick up the
whole pieces basically yeah white is
that's really struggling to make moves
what what possible moves are there he
played the Queen iam it's probably the
the right of the best one and yeah now
explora finds the the next nice move
goes Knight f3 and this is just I think
a very very visual way to play and look
at those pieces they're all on light
squares and it's quite funny this rook
is also working nicely and what is
support of the smooth because I
if white takes what that no meat okay so
this is this is not possible and in fact
what is what is it that what can kill
play here fee
move through the night
nice so quite some some some funny lines
what about this one
whoops winning the Queen
yeah it's really really tough to find a
movie even Yahoo a Makarov played rukka
chuan covering h2 this is the wrath of
the best smooth and now Kasparov went
here increasing the pressure even more
now we are at a position where it's very
difficult to make a move right here and
now quite quite a funny solution
the thing is what does it have a move
and Kasparov played King h8 just passing
the right to move to white and basically
telling him ok I don't think that you
have a move that you can play and yeah
it is it is true basically look at look
at the position he played rook - oops
sorry route to h1 and now the the funny
solution is b5 with the idea to play
before and after this Knight moves away
you will actually take on youtube so b5
let's say a3 a5 and preparing this white
can never take off course of you take
here there are some try this one take
here I take only 2 so you cannot take
here but I'm threatening before and if
you've played before yourself it's just
hanging here so what is what is
basically insuk's 1 something like this
and after before black can break through
yeah a great great detecting game I
always remember a 14-year old it's a
great great concept I think it's just
it's just so nice to see roopd three
Knight f3 this is just just great and of
course this kind of here breakthrough is
very very instructive always need to
check possibilities - to free your
pieces and activate your pieces
this gives the bishop lots of lots of
activity and it also if you look at this
allows the knight to join in on f4 so
this is just just a great result for
black just one pawn invested and you
immediately get get excellent active
play here so great attacking game by the
young Kasparov um yeah I'm looking this
was the first game and I'm looking at a
second one just just a moment here me
too to open this this was a bit much ok
here I just want to look at the decisive
part of the game the end so we go
through this very quickly it is a to
spin tirage defense of the Queen's
Gambit via transposition and Kasparov
maintains some activity in the center
let's go to the to the critical point
that I also so here we're near the
critical point now that's not quickly at
the the names here so Kasparov black as
mentioned we keep his perspective here
on the game from the black site and this
was played in 19 I think in 1981
yeah 1981 in in Graz in Austria and this
was the world under 26 Championships
there's something like I think they
called it the cadets so young players
under 26 of course Kasparov at the time
you can calculate was 18
yeah it was 18 at the time and I think
he easily won this under 26 championship
and he played a Brazilian Grandmaster at
least later Grandmaster I don't think he
was a GM at the time soon leonito very
very good player 2500 level and his
father at the time of course was widely
known as an excellent junior and
potential candidate for the for the
world title he was it was it was a very
fast rise from 1979 80 81 during two or
three years it was okay he will become
the World Championship candidate okay so
look at the position him the Kasparov SS
often has got very active pieces he's
got this look in position the knight to
join and maybe the queen is also so he's
got lots of stuff on the King but if you
look at the position what always
fascinated me about this I saw this game
years ago when I was a kid
and we're always fascinated means that
sometimes in those
in those attacking games you have like
one site has everything positioned very
nicely and it all works together and the
other side has played some NASA some
sub-optimal moves and somehow pieces are
misplaced and so on and it's not so
clear I mean it is clear that that one
side mate made some mistakes and that
piece is not well positioned but look at
this position isn't why it's position
also making sense it's got the rooks
doubled it's got a good knight on d4 a
good bishop here which has some scope so
shouldn't this be okay for what yeah
maybe maybe but let's see what happens
small plates 9h four of course attacking
and here it is very difficult of course
it's not not an easy position but here's
Sonia Nieto takes yeah he plays a
pleasure move which basically blows up
in his face
place 96 and the the amazing thing is
how quickly what gets in trouble but
it's very nice of course so what is this
move to you okay it is it's a discovered
attack on the Queen and of course the
Queen needs to take on the two so not
much choice takes and now Knight f4 this
was Sonia NATO's idea to to attack the
rook and probably they played this also
in the in time trouble it's very very
likely rook to g5 & King Jiwon
so he wants to get the King out of this
so isn't this looking like a relatively
normal position I mean good night here
and to defense good bishop what's I
don't know it looks rather harmless I
mean should should black half
have a great detective okay let's see
what happens neither three played by
Kasparov but it's this really dangerous
okay
the King moves moves to f1 what would
happen if the King moves to to h1 if you
want you can treat this as as a tactical
puzzle here but if you find that this
would be an outstanding achievement I
think because the the point of all this
is is simply amazing
so what black cam can do in this
position this is a very strong move
black can play Bishop takes III what's
the point of this move if the the Queen
takes let's start with the easy ones
yeah this is a checkmate funny mate
okay so much if pawn takes takes here
and this is this is losing now because I
guess all kinds of ideas take here take
here and it's no way to escape this also
loop these three as a problem
so but still what happens if the bishop
is captured and this is the the
absolutely amazing point here this is
the move this is really a really great
night takes and rook g3 and there's rook
h3 mate and it's not possible to defend
this it's just it's just great and UK if
the the knight who moves to defend and
disruption one mate
so black is just playing with the rook
and the night against Queen night and
Bishop but it's an unavoidable mate this
is really worth looking at again takes
here it takes here and then this is
simply over the Queen has just an
unlucky spot on b3 basically I think
almost any out of square that's some way
to and are not ought not any other
square but lots of other squares there
would be a defense but not from d3 so
King h1 loses because of the should be
three so okay
he went to f1 SUNY NATO maybe saw that
or just felt that King each one was was
worse and okay what's happening here
also here you can treat this as a
technical puzzle if you want it's still
it's very difficult but maybe you you
find it anyway I think this is
was also great okay so I'll show the
move now it's again Bishop takes c3 and
this makes it all the more beautiful
because it's it's similar but slow with
the twist yeah okay Bishop III what's
the point if the Queen takes and start
with the easy ones we got this maid
coming
all very very very cute so what's the
threat even the threat is rook takes F
to mate so white cannot ignore all this
or anything he needs to really capture
this is maybe a move that you can can
look at but then there's this check
everything says everything is working
perfectly together check
yeah here can be just a but I'm gonna
want this move
oh my God look at this this is made made
coming Wow check and you need to first
check this rope then this check and
you've got this made or this made me
great just great
forgot this line everything my no it's
but I was just again maze at this okay
so this is 92 after the bishop sec so KY
took it yeah and what means no and it's
the same move the same move this is
amazing and now the point is that also
this fork threatening
so if white takes on g2 now you just
grab he had on exchange and you're on
exchange event the three points so very
easy win so cannot take the look so why
do I played Quincy three this is the the
toughest defense and what now you just
played rock edge to threatening mate
not defend it
yeah and this is now also very nice
what does blacks idea what was what what
what is it what black wants to play yeah
in fact what you want to do is to get
this made and if possible the problem is
if you play this yeah you run into a
rack perpetual so it cannot do that if
you want to win so what did Kasparov
play cutting-edge 7 threatening rook g2
and here white played the muth Quincy 8
so anticipating this route g2 Queen
affair check a little bit of a tougher
defense would have been Queen before but
this also this also wins again I can
show this afterwards so this is what he
played and after this cause probably it
was like this check King f2 and now 92
this was also in the position
threatening rook F 1 mate and in fact
there's only this triad defense
and this is how it ended in fact after
92 Sonia Nieto resigned in view of this
slide after this year he resigned let's
briefly look at what would have happened
if what goes into not here but go into
before which is a bit tougher after this
black cow this is saying plays f5 just
threatening just like protecting this
and now Queen b5 attacking again after
this black has some this motif again and
will win after here right here and now
the cued move f4 attacking the knight
attacking the Queen and like it's a
widest white is helpless against this
it's all at once all pieces are hanging
and you in a mating attack so this
Bishop takes III ideas just just just
great especially this this one fantastic
this made a really deep impression on me
when I was a kid I saw this game right
when I when I started with chess and to
this day I love I love those those mates
in the in the corner this mates on like
this rook takes h3 made or rook h7 or up
g8 made the night and rook combination
maybe it is due to this game I don't
know so very very beautiful it's great
to actually manage to play this in a
game sometimes you have great lines and
in a game that never actually
materialized on the board but to really
have it played out this is great also
the way it was played was also also
great yeah cuz Smurf has played so many
spectacular and and the greats
particular great games that you really
have a hard time to choose it's just an
abundance of great chess yeah thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it and maybe
you you didn't know at this both games I
don't know it's difficult they're very
is so much published so that the games
are very well known I hope you enjoyed
it and I'll be back soon with new and
and other videos I'll be doing that the
Blitz videos daily of course but maybe
during the next couple of days I'll add
to the art video and the evening yeah
thanks for watching and bye